be a part or even be the center of our medical team?
What if Musu could help us bring health care from clinics in cities
to the doorsteps of her neighbors?
Musu was 48 when I met her.
And despite her amazing talent and grit,
she hadn't had a paying job in 30 years.
So what if technology could support her?
What if we could invest in her with real training,
equip her with real medicines,
and have her have a real job?
Well, in 2007, I was trying to answer these questions,
and my wife and I were getting married that year.
We asked our relatives to forgo the wedding registry gifts
and instead donate some money
so we could have some start-up money to launch a nonprofit.
I promise you, I'm a lot more romantic than that.
(Laughter)
We ended up raising $6,000,
teamed up with some Liberians and Americans
and launched a nonprofit called Last Mile Health.
Our goal is to bring a health worker within reach of everyone, everywhere.
We designed a three-step process --
train, equip and pay --
to invest more deeply in volunteers like Musu
to become paraprofessionals,
to become community health workers.
First we trained Musu to prevent, diagnose and treat
the top 10 diseases afflicting families in her village.
A nurse supervisor visited her every month to coach her.
We equipped her with modern medical technology,
like this $1 malaria rapid test,
and put it in a backpack full of medicines like this
to treat infections like pneumonia,
and crucially,
a smartphone, to help her track and report on epidemics.
Last, we recognized the dignity in Musu's work.
With the Liberian government, we created a contract,
paid her
and gave her the chance to have a real job.
And she's amazing.
Musu has learned over 30 medical skills,
from screening children for malnutrition,
to assessing the cause of a child's cough with a smartphone,
to supporting people with HIV
and providing follow-up care to patients who've lost their limbs.
Working as part of our team,
working as paraprofessionals,
community health workers can help ensure
that a lot of what your family doctor would do
reaches the places that most family doctors could never go.
One of my favorite things to do is to care for patients
with community health workers.
So last year I was visiting A.B.,
and like Musu, A.B. had had a chance to go to school.
He was in middle school, in the eighth grade,
when his parents died.
He became an orphan and had to drop out.
Last year, we hired and trained A.B. as a community health worker.
And while he was making door to door house calls,
he met this young boy named Prince,
whose mother had had trouble breastfeeding him,
and by the age of six months, Prince had started to waste away.
A.B. had just been taught how to use this color-coded measuring tape
that wraps around the upper arm of a child to diagnose malnutrition.
A.B. noticed that Prince was in the red zone,
which meant he had to be hospitalized.
So A.B. took Prince and his mother to the river,
got in a canoe
and paddled for four hours to get to the hospital.
Later, after Prince was discharged,
A.B. taught mom how to feed baby a food supplement.
A few months ago,
A.B. took me to visit Prince, and he's a chubby little guy.
(Laughter)
He's meeting his milestones, he's pulled himself up to a stand,
and is even starting to say a few words.
I'm so inspired by these community health workers.
I often ask them why they do what they do,
and when I asked A.B.,
he said, "Doc, since I dropped out of school, this is the first time
I'm having a chance to hold a pen to write.
My brain is getting fresh."
The stories of A.B. and Musu have taught me something fundamental
about being human.
Our will to serve others
can actually help us transform our own conditions.
I was so moved by how powerful the will to serve our neighbors can be
a few years ago,
when we faced a global catastrophe.
In December 2013,
something happened in the rainforests across the border from us in Guinea.
A toddler named Emile fell sick with vomiting, fever and diarrhea.
He lived in an area where the roads were sparse
and there had been massive shortages of health workers.
Emile died,
and a few weeks later his sister died,
and a few weeks later his mother died.
And this disease would spread from one community to another.
And it wasn't until three months later
that the world recognized this as Ebola.
When every minute counted, we had already lost months,
and by then the virus had spread like wildfire all across West Africa,
and eventually to other parts of the world.
Businesses shut down, airlines started canceling routes.
At the height of the crisis,
when we were told that 1.4 million people could be infected,
when we were told that most of them would die,
when we had nearly lost all hope,
I remember standing with a group of health workers
in the rainforest where an outbreak had just happened.
We were helping train and equip them to put on the masks,
the gloves and the gowns that they needed
to keep themselves safe from the virus
while they were serving their patients.
I remember the fear in their eyes.
And I remember staying up at night, terrified if I'd made the right call
to keep them in the field.
When Ebola threatened to bring humanity to its knees,
Liberia's community health workers didn't surrender to fear.
They did what they had always done:
they answered the call to serve their neighbors.
Community members across Liberia learned the symptoms of Ebola,
teamed up with nurses and doctors to go door-to-door to find the sick
and get them into care.
They tracked thousands of people who had been exposed to the virus
and helped break the chain of transmission.
Some ten thousand community health workers risked their own lives
to help hunt down this virus and stop it in its tracks.
(Applause)
Today, Ebola has come under control in West Africa,
and we've learned a few things.
We've learned that blind spots in rural health care
can lead to hot spots of disease,
and that places all of us at greater risk.
We've learned that the most efficient emergency system
is actually an everyday system,
and that system has to reach all communities,
including rural communities like Emile's.
And most of all,
we've learned from the courage of Liberia's community health workers
that we as people are not defined by the conditions we face,
no matter how hopeless they seem.
We're defined by how we respond to them.
For the past 15 years,
I've seen the power of this idea
to transform everyday citizens into community health workers --
into everyday heroes.
And I've seen it play out everywhere,
from the forest communities of West Africa,
to the rural fishing villages of Alaska.
It's true,
these community health workers aren't doing neurosurgery,
but they're making it possible
to bring health care within reach of everyone everywhere.
So now what?
Well, we know that there are still millions of people dying
from preventable causes
in rural communities around the world.
And we know that the great majority of these deaths are happening
in these 75 blue-shaded countries.
What we also know
is that if we trained an army of community health workers
to learn even just 30 lifesaving skills,
we could save the lives of nearly 30 million people by 2030.
Thirty services could save 30 million lives by 2030.
That's not just a blueprint --
we're proving this can be done.
In Liberia,
the Liberian government is training thousands of workers like A.B. and Musu
after Ebola,
to bring health care to every child and family in the country.
And we've been honored to work with them,
and are now teaming up with a number of organizations
that are working across other countries
to try to help them do the same thing.
If we could help these countries scale,
we could save millions of lives,
and at the same time,
we could create millions of jobs.
We simply can't do that, though, without technology.
People are worried that technology is going to steal our jobs,
but when it comes to community health workers,
technology has actually been vital for creating jobs.
Without technology -- without this smartphone,
without this rapid test --
it would have been impossible for us to be able to employ A.B. and Musu.
And I think it's time for technology to help us train,
to help us train people faster and better than ever before.
As a doctor,
I use technology to stay up-to-date and keep certified.
I use smartphones, I use apps, I use online courses.
But when A.B. wants to learn,
he's got to jump back in that canoe
and get to the training center.
And when Musu shows up for training,
her instructors are stuck using flip charts and markers.
Why shouldn't they have the same access to learn as I do?
If we truly want community health workers to master those lifesaving skills
and even more,
we've got to change this old-school model of education.
Tech can truly be a game changer here.
I've been in awe of the digital education revolution
that the likes of Khan Academy and edX have been leading.
And I've been thinking that it's time;
it's time for a collision
between the digital education revolution
and the community health revolution.
And so, this brings me to my TED Prize wish.
I wish --
I wish that you would help us recruit
the largest army of community health workers the world has ever known
by creating the Community Health Academy,
a global platform to train, connect and empower.
(Applause)
Thank you.
Here's the idea:
we'll create and curate
the best in digital education resources.
We will bring those to community health workers around the world,
including A.B. and Musu.
They'll get video lessons on giving kids vaccines
and have online courses on spotting the next outbreak,
so they're not stuck using flip charts.
We'll help these countries accredit these workers,
so that they're not stuck remaining an under-recognized, undervalued group,
but become a renowned, empowered profession,
just like nurses and doctors.
And we'll create a network of companies and entrepreneurs
who've created innovations that can save lives
and help them connect to workers like Musu,
so she can help better serve her community.
And we'll work tirelessly to persuade governments
to make community health workers a cornerstone of their health care plans.
We plan to test and prototype the academy in Liberia
and a few other partner countries,
and then we plan to take it global,
including to rural North America.
With the power of this platform,
we believe countries can be more persuaded
that a health care revolution really is possible.
My dream is that this academy will contribute to the training
of hundreds of thousands of community members
to help bring health care to their neighbors --
the hundreds of millions of them
that live in the world's most remote communities,
from the forest communities of West Africa,
to the fishing villages of rural Alaska;
from the hilltops of Appalachia, to the mountains of Afghanistan.
If this vision is aligned with yours,
head to communityhealthacademy.org,
and join this revolution.
Let us know if you or your organization or someone you know could help us
as we try to build this academy over the next year.
Now, as I look out into this room,
I realize that our journeys are not self-made;
they're shaped by others.
And there have been so many here that have been part of this cause.
We're so honored to be part of this community,
and a community that's willing to take on a cause
as audacious as this one,
so I wanted to offer, as I end,
a reflection.
I think a lot more about what my father taught me.
These days, I too have become a dad.
I have two sons,
and my wife and I just learned that she's pregnant with our third child.
(Applause)
Thank you.
I was recently caring for a woman in Liberia
who, like my wife, was in her third pregnancy.
But unlike my wife,
had had no prenatal care with her first two babies.
She lived in an isolated community in the forest that had gone for 100 years
without any health care
until ...
until last year when a nurse trained her neighbors
to become community health workers.
So here I was,
seeing this patient who was in her second trimester,
and I pulled out the ultrasound to check on the baby,
and she started telling us stories about her first two kids,
and I had the ultrasound probe on her belly,
and she just stopped mid-sentence.
She turned to me and she said,
"Doc, what's that sound?"
It was the first time she'd ever heard her baby's heartbeat.
And her eyes lit up in the same way my wife's eyes and my own eyes lit up
when we heard our baby's heartbeat.
For all of human history,
illness has been universal and access to care has not.
But as a wise man once told me:
no condition is permanent.
It's time.
It's time for us to go as far as it takes
to change this condition together.
Thank you.
(Applause)